I call it the Taylor Swift rule so I
think Taylor Swift hacked culture what
Taylor Swift's very good at is she knows
that when people tweet her and say
Taylor come to my wedding and sing me a
song she actually does it here's why she
does it the 75-minute allocation of her
time to do something like that is not
Roi positive for Taylor based on what
she makes for her time however the
amplification of doing something that
makes no sense on paper is where she
gets all her value so I get yelled out
by all my smartest CEO friends the most
fancy gals and guys on Earth for still
answering all these tweets and emails
and replying one by one on Snapchat but
I know that depth is far more
interesting than with in a world where
the width has just become completely
obnoxiously loud and impossible to break
through you scale
the unscalable if you want to break
through the noise today